la lucha juvenil contra el calentamiento
global volvió a las calles este viernes
después de un año y medio de
restricciones por la pandemia para
exigir medidas urgentes que eviten las
desastrosas consecuencias de la crisis
climática yo creo que lo que él logró
aportar la juventud a la lucha climática
primero es un poco resignificar la no
agregarle toda esta parte social la
parte derechos humanos que antes la
agenda asociaba la crítica maría con un
oso polar en argentina miles de
activistas medioambientales se
concentraron ante el congreso para
protestar contra un proyecto de ley de
combustibles fósiles que beneficiaría a
las empresas petroleras
en brasil las manifestaciones estuvieron
dirigidas contra las políticas
climáticas de jair bolsonaro y
recordaron los incendios que destruyen
la amazonía
alimentados por la persistente
deforestación durante el gobierno de
bolsonaro la tasa alcanzó más de 10.000
kilómetros cuadrados de bosques en dos
años
en ciudad de méxico la huelga climática
global inició con una campaña contra
pemex la empresa petrolera estatal
méxico es uno de los países más bien
tratados que en latinoamérica tenemos
los cafés tenemos sentido tenemos
inundaciones
tenemos golpes de calor los guarismos de
fer nos morimos de calor y el gobierno
sigue financiando la industria de
combustibles fósiles la huelga mundial
llega después de que la onu advirtiera
que la crisis climática se aceleró tras
la pandemia de coronavirus pero que una
acción rápida y a gran escala a wind
podría evitar algunos de los impactos
más destructivos